jonathan tabarre bonjour bonjour
monsieur livory bonjour à tous les
auditeurs de martinique 1ère à la radio
alors que notre candidat ait l'air et
donc du groupe l'avenir avec audace sur
la première circonscription celle du
centre tout à fait quel est le sens de
votre candidature mais vous savez ma
candidature je vous dise est une
continuité en 2017 j'étais déjà candidat
suppléant de karine rousseau et en 2022
je suis candidat sur mon propre
événement donc c'est une candidature que
j'ai préparé pendant toutes ces années
j'ai travaillé sur tous les sujets tous
les dossiers qui touchent la martinique
et qui sont très importants pour le
développement de notre île nous allons y
revenir pourquoi il n'y a pas d'entente
d'unités avec jl godard de lui dire
votre question me fait bien sourire
effectivement il ya un partenariat dans
le cadre des élections présidentielles
entre l'idée y est les républicains mais
aujourd'hui pour les actrices
législatives les républicains font leur
route et jaune a totalement trace son
chemin mais quels sont les trois grandes
mesures que vous développez pendant la
campagne mais vous avez la vie chère
c'est un sujet qui nous touchent
principalement en martinique et moi j po
ambitions et rigueur d'attaqué
sérieusement l'octroi de mer qui
étonnait pour qui quand même elle juge
que paye tous les martiniquais mais ça
permet quand même de voilà de financer
les collectivités mais c'est trop facile
de dire que ça finances des
collectivités sage je l'entends mais que
faisons-nous de la population
martiniquaise qui sauf qu'il ne peut
plus se nourrir correctement qui ne peut
plus habillés qui ne peut plus acheter
sans payer des articles qui sont chères
parce que si bien beau de dire que ça
finances des collectivités territoriales
mais vous savez qu'en france hexagonale
il n'ya pas docteur de mer et les
collectivités territoriales trouve le
moyen de se financer donc il va nous
falloir sérieusement en tant qu'élu en
tant que député résoudre ce poème de
l'auteur de mer et que je vous rappelle
qu'ils datent de 1670 en place autour du
maire par quoi vous savez la france est
championne du monde en création d'impôts
m elle devra être championne du monde
dotation pour les collectivités la
réalisation globale de fonctionnement
diminuent chaque année m il faudra
travailler parce que vous savez nous
avons un rattrapage la fnaut doigt comme
je le dis dans ma campagne la fosse l'on
doit nous avons autant sur la santé sous
le social sous l'éducation sous
l'économie il faudrait que la france
mettra la main à la pour le vous savez a
eu l'air que ce qu vide le président à
maquereau a décrété le quoiqu'il en
croûte et bien va devoir décrété le
crois qu'il en coûte pour la martinique
et pour l'ensemble des outre-mer oui moi
vous dire qu'il ya pas d'argent non
sitôt phase 2 qui a pas d'argent on a su
trouver tous les centaines de millions
d'euros pour résoudre pour la crise qu
vite pour acheter des vaccins mais là il
va devoir on va devoir trouver si les
centaines de millions d'euros qui manque
à notre économie qui manque à nos
territoires quels autres thèmes
développés dans votre cour de votre
copain italgas pour moi l'environnement
c'est important parce que vous savez
dans ma circonscription mais pas
seulement mais sur toute la martinique
nous sommes envahis par les algues
sargasse mais moi ce que je propose
c'est que le gouvernement crée et
notamment les députés une mesure qui est
d'état de catastrophe climatique et non
naturel pour une thématique parce que la
saga est due à l'activité humaine
est due à l'activité humaine donc cette
prolifération c'est nous qui la région
c'est des sommes qu'il a créés et quand
le 10ème clarion c'est pas forcément les
martiniquais ça vient de loin sam de la
mer des sargasses aux alentours du
brésil dans la mer des caraïbes environ
donc on subit quelque chose que nous
n'avons pas choisi donc il faudra que
l'état se prennent en main et prennent
en charge ce second volume des sargasses
je me battrai à l'assemblée nationale
pour que cet état de catastrophe
climatique jeudi mais climatique et non
naturelle soit reconnu pour protéger nos
populations parce qu'il faut savoir que
les premiers réfugiés climatiques
ils ne sont pas aux îles fidji ils sont
en martinique sur le littoral et ces
personnes là qu'ils ont sur le littoral
qui subissent la faune des algues
sargasse eh bien il va devra falloir
lire au logis parce que certains
surnomment déjà les tuyaux des terres
mais très difficilement est ce un
problème qui est entier et moi je me
bats pour que cet état de 14 ans je me
battrai pour que cet état de catastrophe
climatique soit reconnue par l'état et
qu'on fait et que des assurances
prennent toute la mesure de des dégâts
que causent des sagas sur le matériel
parce que les habitants qui sont sur le
littoral vous savez quoi ils changent
bien souvent leur matériel trois à
quatre fois par année et ben non moi je
dis qu'on doit pouvoir permettre à ses
habitants la dette remboursée d'être
pris en charge à 100 % à 100 % il encore
il faudra que l'état mette en place un
plan de solidarité pour aider toutes ces
populations qui vivent ce littoral on a
le fonds soit on à trinité on a le
robert ca foule lorsque vous allez dans
certains quartiers de ces communes après
yad autres communes de la martinique
mais pour l'instant je parle de ceux que
je rencontre sûrement sur ma
circonscription
alors face caméra qu'avez vous à dire à
la population de votre circonscription
pour qu'elle vote pour vous moi j'avais
dans la population de la circonscription
du centre qui se compose des communes du
fonds soit du goût monde du lamentin du
hautbert et de la trinité de faire le
choix de jonathan tabac le choix de
jonathan tabassé le choix de l'avenir
avec audace mais surtout le choix de la
martinique avec audace moi je suis une
candidature crédible ça fait plusieurs
années que je me prépare je vais à la
rencontre de la population la population
est satisfaite la population vient me
voir m'accueille les vagues ont ouvert
ils disent que monsieur vous avez un
disco qui change des autres candidats et
j'ai mis cette population à me soutenir
et à regarder en face qui est jonathan
tabac et qui est le cas le candidat de
l'avenir avec audace pour la martinique
je vois bien si jonathan tabac je vous
remercie c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]